so hi everyone I'd like to thank you for
braving the cold to come all the way
here I came all the way from Boston in
the cold it was really cold um and I to
start by saying that um this is going to
be an interpretive talk about the paper
which means that I will talk about the
paper but the paper was so long ago that
a lot has happened since then so I will
talk about some work that has been done
uh the work happened to be work that I
did so I know
it so I'm not cheating or anything I
promise um and also I want to say this
is kind of a feel-good talk so there are
some scary words here like axiomatic and
computer but it's going to be okay I'm
not going to use those words very much
all right I'll tell you what they mean
one of
them so let's start by talking about why
we want to prove software correct right
so I
mean so the funny thing is I was giving
a talk about this once and I put this
and I pretended I didn't know what
happened but I put that there
guys um so yeah when you're making some
slides you haven't saved yet and you're
like oh crap I have to give a talk in an
hour but I'm not going to have any talk
and then you know it says do you wish to
debug and you say I don't know how to
debug this so a side story is that my
adviser one time was in the similar
situation where he was making some
slides for a class all morning he didn't
save I don't know what his deal is and
then he was like I have no choice I have
to
debug he managed to step his program out
of an infinite Loop he was just like
just like kept on stepping it and he's
like okay it's infinite looping I'm just
going to put it outside of the loop and
it worked so like if it happens to you
oh
shoot
happen all right right cool that we uh
we can't prevent things like that but
you know um so yeah that was like a
whole line of research after that but
you know yeah so um when bugs happen uh
not only does your talk get delayed but
you know you could lose all of your data
Maybe years worth of data right but the
good thing is now we have the cloud so
that can back things up but the bad
thing is the cloud can leak all of our
data now because there's just another
source of bugs right and so um if you
were alive last year um you um you heard
of heart bleed which was a result of
what like a memory bounds check uh
someone didn't check some memory this
could have been prevented If Only They
had some aums and
some so um so it's not just our data
that is in danger but also our lives so
who's heard of this Toyota acceleration
bug yeah so like probably more of us
should have heard of this because um
there's a bug in Toyota cars that caused
them to randomly accelerate which is
very dangerous if you've ridden in a car
you should know
this and so yeah so Toyota is putting a
lot of effort actually into proving
software programs to be correct because
you know more and more of cars are
running on uh software and if it's not
correct you can die um and also there's
like other famous bugs like one time
this Korea air plane crashed because
there was some case they didn't consider
where um it was hydrop pointing but
they're like well if your wheels aren't
moving then you can't stop um because
you're in the air um and so and the
plane crashed so you know the whole yeah
so software bugs really lead to the
apocalypse and we should be really
worried except for there's this
paper yeah that's pretty much a talk go
um so yeah we can take comfort or not
the software is being produced in very
uh calm environments like this where um
you know the social network and
anecdotal evidence and personal
experience tell us that people tend to
drink a lot of alcohol when producing
software programs and um we should
really trust our software for this
reason and so I mean this is really the
equivalent of uh trusting a guy who
looks like this to build our bridges
right um which is not the best idea but
good thing there's such a thing as
inspection for Bridges right we load
test our bridges we can measure the
bridge to make sure it's not crooked to
make sure it's not going to fall down
right um but the thing is what's the
equivalent for software right so how how
do we make sure our software isn't going
to kill us and so this is an interactive
part of the talk where we can we can
think about this um having read the
paper we can like withhold from that
part but how do how do other people make
sure software is correct write a spec
you can write a spec yeah t of testing a
lot of testing right deploy production
and see what breaks right
yeah yeah it
really yeah they're
hiring for you
guys yeah so so there's testing right
which is kind of like goling saying I
looked in the mirror five times and
every time I look good so therefore I
must look good everything is good right
um so the problem when you're doing this
with the situation outside of r Gosling
is
that there are more inputs to the system
than just run Gosling who always looks
good and so like in testing normally
what happens is like you have this
hypothesis like my program is correct
and here are the reasons why right you
have like these ways you want to test
the hypothesis like okay like there are
these inputs there are those inputs and
there are those inputs right but usually
you have this like really big input
space and your program is really big and
complicated and it's pretty hard to
cover all the possible spaces and so
real life is more complicated running
glass l in conclusion
um but so another approach we can take
is logical reasoning where you have this
set of facts that you build up about
what you assume to be true over uh the
entire world um and you deduce that you
know if uh certain facts hold then you
can prove other facts and if those facts
hold then you know no matter what inputs
happen in your program assuming you
model the program correctly then um you
know that's equivalent to testing like
all possible inputs in your program
right so back to the Ryan Gosling case
it's like Ryan Gosling saying I'm
wearing a suit Ryan Gosling looks good
in suit therefore I must look good right
and this is kind of like those geometry
proofs this is a very small picture of
that to remind you that um you might
have done a geometry class where you
like draw a triangle you draw some lines
on the triangle and then you write some
numbers and then you get an A
um so yeah so in this talk we'll talk
about a logical reasoning based approach
to making sure that your program works
all the time and not just in some
cases and so um the ingredients of this
logical approach are this axioms the
axioms are part of what word that we saw
that was kind of
scary a yeah um so axioms are the set of
facts that we have to work with and um
what we want to do is we want to build
theorems out of those aums and how we
build the theorems is out based on
deduction rules and so oxums are kind of
like Legos um we're allowed to put Legos
together as long as you know the holes
go into the things or the things go into
the holes um and then like anything we
can build um that's well I guess like
the holes going into the things you know
that those are our deduction rules and
then the things we build out of our
oxums or theorems and then those can in
turn be you know used the same as Axiom
to be involved in more deduction rules
and then we can prove bigger and bigger
things
right cool everyone is still here um all
right so then um we can start by talking
about some rules of D deductive logic
just to give you a feel for like how
this works and so the the Detachment
rule uh says that if P implies Q uh and
P are true so everything above the line
is uh things that we assume to be true
and the thing below the line is our
conclusion so if we have P implies q and
P then uh Q is true so this is a
slightly different syntax than I seen in
the paper so in the paper you have these
like Turn Style things like a line and
Dash so instead we're using these lines
cuz that's the modern way of doing it um
so bringing this back to our running
example we have um if you are Ryan
Gosling we know that this this
implication is true that if you are Ryan
Gosling when you book you established
that so if you are ran Gosling what
happens yeah guys you're doing really
great at
logic all right so now let's look at how
we chain these implications together
right so um if you have p p in q and Q
implies R and P is true then uh R
follows from that right so that's kind
of like saying um if you are Ryan
Gosling then you have great hair all
people with great hair look good and so
if you are Ryan
Gosling you look
good so are are there questions
confusions
so really just the tribute to Ryan
Gosling um
all right so now uh final one we have is
Contra positive so if we have P implies
q and we have not Q then what follows is
not p and so to illustrate this point we
bring back our
friend actually we never saw him before
he's not our friend if you are Ryan
Gosling you look good so if you don't
look good you must not be Ryan Gosling
right and
so the note here is that if you're not
running Gosling you could look good or
you could look bad but I mean does
anyone really
care and so all right we have some
deductive logic rules now we can move on
so does
everyone understand so far are there
questions so
far can we can we see another picture of
Ryan Goslin uh yeah don't worry okay
yeah you think I am um all right so we
have um we have this nice basis for
reasoning about things right but about
programs right so programs are really
complicated there are lots of parts to
them and um it's not always easy to
characterize them and so now we know how
to reason but how do we reason about
programs right and so reasoning about
programs was uh hores contribution well
so like it's questionable it's not
questionable but um so well okay there
are many people who contributed to
reasoning about programs but wh was the
best writer out of all of them and so
his paper gets cited the most and so let
this be a lesson to the
world and so yeah so this is the the
contribution of this paper and
everything else I'll be talking about um
and so there was some previous work by
um Pearlman and someone whose name
starts with the G Guinness and Floyd on
characterizing program state right and
so there are many ways you can
characterize the state of a program and
uh usually like you know you
characterize the part of program state
that matters to you and here some
examples of valid ways you can describe
program state right so I can say that my
variable X is equal to three that's a
description of my program state right I
can say Y is greater than x if x is not
equal to zero then y + z = w this could
be true I don't know um I can say s is
the summation of all the things all the
elements I and something a maybe an
array and I can say something this is a
for all I can say for all I um from one
to n you know the I element of a
probably an array is greater than the
previous element of the array and also I
can just say true yeah true is a true
thing about my program
State um and so so we have all this and
people were sort of um characterizing
programs and ways like this Floyd had a
paper on flowcharts before this and the
big contribution that horse paper did
was it introduced this thing called the
hor triple for characterizing programs
so what the hor triple says is that you
have this program so it's a contract
about um what it means for your program
to be correct right so in a hor triple
you have a precondition which is what
needs to be satisfied in order for uh
everything else to be true you have your
program which is the program and then
you have a post condition which is what
is true if your precondition is
satisfied and the program ran right so
um in order for the whole thing to be
satisfied two things have to be true
right so the precondition has to hold
and also your program has to
terminate and
so so so you'll see yeah these these two
things are really big assumptions but as
long as those two things hold then the
post condition is true and so this is
called partial correctness because um
there's so there's there's a theorem
that you can't tell if a program is
going to terminate and um you know if
your program doesn't terminate then you
can have whatever post condition you
want and so now we we will look at some
example hor triples and these things
will come into count right or come into
play so uh the first thing is well if
you have true starting with this
assignment of x to five uh then
afterwards X = 5es right and so here we
have a program that assigns X to x + 3
and so if x is equal to Y before this
program then X is equal to y + 3 after
the program right so now we have a
program that multiplies X by two if x
was greater than zero before the program
then X is greater than -2 after the
program right um and so then this one
the next one is also similar right we
have like if x is less than zero then we
take Negative X we're taking the
absolute value so if x is equal to some
a x is equal to the absolute value of a
after the program the next one is
interesting so uh this one I don't know
I don't think this lasor point works but
x = 3 um false is true beforehand and
xal 8 is true after so what's going on
there have
F right exactly so the false
precondition never hold so we can just
put whatever you want for the Post
Condition it's still a about valid hor
triple
right and then the next case is also
interesting so what's going on
there right so we have this while true
do x = x + 1 right so we're essentially
incrementing the variable X forever um
so it never terminates so that's why we
can just say false for our post
condition we can say anything because
the program never terminates so in
general you're not going to know if the
termin right right but um but for for
this program well yeah but yeah can you
make it undefined
there you can put anything you want
after this non-terminating program yeah
the triple the contract is only that if
the precognition holds and the the
program terminates right so if those two
things don't hold whatever post
condition you want can be
there Ryan golin can be the post
condition of Ryan gson being the post
conditioner
always um it was pointed out to me that
actually this is not
true because at some point Ryan Gosling
will die
um but you know what yeah so I I'm
thinking more about the platonic Ryan
Gosling and not Ryan Gosling with hum so
I I think we're fine here actually any
program some programs may not Hal so I
don't know that that or triple is really
Val it's always the programs that don't
hold anything is
valid so for those programs especially
Brian goling can really do theog changes
ran um you're right there's some
problems here guys this is just to
illustrate some
point we're going to move on
no side effects yeah yeah he's keep
immutable um so now we get to the rules
from the paper guys um so you read the
paper you don't have to tell me actually
no don't tell me anyone um let's just
keep going so um so the assignment rule
from the paper which all of you read um
we have uh X X+ 1 and we want to say x
is less than or equal to n after right
and so if you'll recall from the paper
uh we have this axium schema so what it
means to be an aium schema is that it's
not an axium it's something that tells
you how to make aums so it's telling us
how to make this axum um and so it says
that if x is a variable identifier f is
an expression and P is obtained from P
by substituting f for all occurrences of
X right so um what should go and
box exactly yeah good work everyone
and so um to illustrate this point with
our running example um so we have uh xal
X Plus suit and then we get Ryan Gosling
in the suit after so we should go
before what's
that we don't know anything do we have
any deduction rules for that yet
no so wait what goes
down we haven't seen naked Ry go yet we
don't have rules for that
yet it's possible but we can't prove it
um prove you
Su R yeah so we have X Plus suit equals
Ryan I thing um so right so that's
assignment we have assignment rule so
far are there any questions about
assignment okay cool yeah Ranon makes
everything clear um I have a question
yes not a funny
question um we were talking about hor
triples and then we started talking
about schemas for axium right is is
essentially a hor triple an axium is
that one way of thinking about
it yeah so okay sorry if you want to say
that part because I got distracted by
um yeah so so there really two
contributions of this paper
uh one is this way of characterizing
programs and so like characterizing the
specifications for what it means for a
program to be correct right and then
once we have that characterization we
need a way to prove that
characterization right and so we need a
way for a computer to automatically go
through and or a computer plus a human
or some combination of something to go
through and deduce theorems from the
axioms right and so what the assignment
rule schema and all these other rules do
is they're providing a way to go from
aiom to the and so right
yeah um all right so
um so now uh usually programs are made
up of multiple functions right so the
composition rule tells us what to do if
we have multiple things and we want to
chain them together right so if we have
a precondition p a program q1 a
postcondition R1 and then another
program Q2 with precondition R1 and
postcondition r then we can say that uh
if we have precondition q uh P we can
chain q1 and Q2 together and we get the
post condition R right um and so some
examples of this are um if we have a
program that increments X by1 and we
have X is greater than one before the
program and X is greater than two after
the program and then we have another
program where that does the same thing
except we know X is greater than two
before the program and greater than
three after the program we can chain
them together and know that X than one
before we everything and it's greater
than three after the whole thing right
and so this is really useful because
like you can um an an automated prover
can go through and change your different
functions together once you've proven
little properties about them so if Ryan
Gosling's wearing two suits he's just as
good looking as he's wearing one suit if
you have some rules for that
yeah um right so um now the thing that
we want to do which is um we have the
same first program and we're taking the
negative X for the second program and we
have the precognition that if x is
greater than zero before we run this
then X is going to be less than zero
after we run it um and so if we want to
change these two
together what can we say about the post
condition based on the rules we have so
far so someone said not much and why is
that R1 is not the same right exactly is
not the same we don't have the same R1
and so with the rules we have already we
actually cannot chain these together
based on things we've seen
already
but yeah so we have a consequence rule
which tells us how to use implication to
change things together right so if you
have a p p is a precondition for a
program q and R is a post condition and
R implies s you can replace
uh r with s and you can replace S with P
if s implies p as the prec
condition and so now that we have the
consequence rule we can go through and
we can say well X is greater than two
implies X is greater than Z and so now
we can say x is less than
Z and so the question you asked before
like why are we defining all these rules
well we're defining them so someone can
go through and uh someone or some
machine can go through and methodically
produce the things we want to prove
based on the aums we have about what's
true so are there questions at this
point I know you guys all have a
question when is Ry goon coming back so
he's coming back um and so uh so if
you'll recall we had uh this rule which
is you know we assign Ryan Gosling to
Ryan Gosling SU we got him in the suit
and what was our precondition and some
people are wondering about naked run
goling right so so what would it take to
um to see that Ryan Gosling was not
wearing anything before we assigned into
a suit that's a half
naked um so I didn't know what the Like
rules were
for decency of the talk so I didn't want
to take any risks you know only if he
was wearing X plus half a suit well this
is like kind of half a suit you know um
yeah exactly so so this guy here says
you would have to say that um you know
if uh if X plus 2 equals R Gosling then
X had to equal uh Ryan Gosling without a
suit to begin with and so if we had this
rule right this allows us to say Ryan
goling was not wearing anything before
which is what everyone
wants not you
shouldn't it be the other way
around yeah I think the middle line
needs to be reversed to
be oh you're right actually good good
that was I put that there
to yeah you're right this actually
should be switched around but um yeah so
we will do that next time it's a bug
into slides yeah it's a SL didn't verify
them
um cool so um so we also have iteration
now um so this rule is a little bit
complicated you don't really have to
understand it but I put a little key
there to help you understand it if you
do um so we have while B do s um so
that's what the while Loops look like
back in the day of horse paper um and so
if you know that P is true before um and
P is true after the extra thing that
happens is uh not be is also true after
so you have um is true and then B is the
precondition for for going into the loop
and then p is the post condition for the
loop um you can have
this this property when you come out yes
is this assuming side effect free
operations the wild Loop could change
right so so the thing is that's a really
good question um so p is what's called
The Loop invariant and so it is
something that is true even if side
effects happen inside the loop and so um
it's actually very hard to find this P
so I show some examples of using the
iteration Rule and then I'll talk about
a little bit about how hard it is to
find that P but um but yeah so you do
have to find a p that holds throughout
the whole thing yeah use they use that a
lot right yeah yeah um right and so so
here are just some basic examples of uh
using U using the iteration rule so we
have while X is less than 10 do x = x +
1 so this is just really simple true is
true before the loop iterates and true
is true after Loop iterates and then the
extra property we get is less uh X is
now greater than or equal to 10 after
the loop right um we can have a slightly
more interesting property that X is
greater than zero so like if we know
that is true before the loop iterates we
can also show that that is true after
the loop
iterates um and so with loops there's a
whole interesting body of work that has
happened after this paper which is
finding uh so there there are these
Notions of
uh weakest precondition so what is the
weakest statement that needs to hold
before um before your your program
happens in order for everything else to
hold and uh there's the notion of
strongest postn condition so what is the
strongest thing you can say about after
the program executes and then there's
this concept of a loop invariant so an
invariant is something that is true no
matter if all the other state changes
and so so your question is actually a
very good one because so there's a
there's a notion that the state has to
change because if the state's not
changing then an invariant doesn't
really do very much right so the
invariant is what stays the same if all
the other state changes and um there's a
whole body of work on finding Loop and
variance and um so actually finding um
finding there's a thing called the
strongest Loop variant which is the
strongest possible PE that holds and
that is undecidable so uh does someone
want to tell me what it means for
something to be
undecidable it's really
hard
what's that ass right so you can't you
can't you can't assign an algorithm for
figuring out what it means right and so
um so what it means for something to be
undecidable is you can write a procedure
to compute it but you have no guarantee
that that will ever finish and so some
examples of things that are undecidable
are determining whether a program ever
terminates um and there are a lot of
other problems that are undecidable and
people often prove that you know doing
this is equivalent to determining
whether program terminates so yeah so
finding the strongest loen variant in
many domains most domains is equivalent
to deciding whether a program terminates
essentially um but it doesn't mean that
we can't find Lubin variants it just
means that um if we try to find them the
procedure to find them might infinite
Loop it might give us a loop and variant
but it's not the strongest so in
practice there are tools that will find
these Loop and variants but we just
don't have guarantees that they will
terminate or give us the best one can
you still prove aloric corre
strong um yeah right you can still you
can still approve what you have but um
you just so so often if you don't have
the strongest one you won't be able to
prove things that you know are true um
so yeah so the problem with all these
proof tools is that um often you'll know
something is true and that you should be
able to prove it but there's no uh
automated algorithm that that can prove
it to you because of this
undecidability um and uh but if you can
prove it then it's definitely true yeah
yes add Underside abilities for all
possible programs you can still find
programs that hold right but Underside
abilties for all you can't find an
algorithm all possible algorithms right
right then there are domains like like
certain data structures for which it is
a so does that mean that you can like
just assert that to be an axium and like
put it sort of like as a precond
condition if you know it's true but you
can't prove it um so if you know it's
true but you can't prove it you could
acti it but that's really dangerous so
when
you're true right right because like so
when you're trying to prove something
especially in an automated way you
really want this automated assurance
that what you thought was true is
um something yeah is in fact Ausable
from like the axm right so you can aze
the hard Parts but then you that that
goes into your trusted Bas and you
really want to minimize that as much as
possible in general actually what you
can't prove is true work
yeah so like yeah you can so like I
guess like the the trap doors you can
just aze things but um then you don't
know yeah it's just a
postul
yeah all right cool so
um so uh so here's an example of
characterizing programs are uh in horror
logic in real life and so this is a
program that uh what does this program
do
I'll give you guys a second read
it exactly yeah so this is um this is
called sum so you can look at it that
way or you can see that you have this
sum variable that's being assigned to
zero you have this integer I that's your
uh loop variable and then while I is
less than the length um which I got this
from someone else and there's a
typo but uh I think that's supposed to
be
L and uh
see I put that there
happen yeah yeah this is how this is how
bug perpetuate yeah so we're going
through we're taking all the elements of
the array and then we're summing over
them and we're returning the sum right
and so in uh modern automated tools this
is an example of something you can do so
you can say you require the the length
of the array to be greater than or equal
to zero and the actual array length to
be equal to line which you're
and then you can say this ensures that
the result is the sum over the elements
of the
array yeah so this is a very handwavy
sort
of yeah but but yeah so this is really
just to give you an idea of uh these are
the sorts of things you can
write maybe we should stop propagating
this slide
um but this is a uh don't send it to
Toyota yeah they they might just put
into their cars
directly yeah um so so there are
actually automated tools that will
um that will check this for you so
there's this tool called Boogie and so
this is this is cool because this is a
terminal that you can uh just pull up in
your browser and you can make programs
with preconditions and post conditions
and check them uh in the browser or you
know if you download the tool you can do
that too but um but yeah so the cool
thing about Boogie is that it's fully
automated so you write preconditions and
post conditions you have to say some
other things like what variables your
function is modifying but it's
essentially like Pascal or a simple
imperative language with prec conditions
and post conditions that it verifies
automatically um and so there are parts
of Boogie that are
undecidable so what does that
mean canot be computer yeah so there are
parts of Boogie where you just like try
to verify something it just never stops
in that case you just control see that
and um you try to put some extra
conditions and you hope it works um so
this is how dealing with undecidability
works in the real
world and so um so I'm bringing up
Boogie because I used it to verify the
type uh safety of an operating system a
few years ago so this is a project I
worked on um and so the idea is
operating systems for a long time where
the Grail of verification right so um
operating systems are really complex
systems and they also make up the
foundation for all the other software so
if you can make sure that certain
properties of operating systems hold
then you can make sure the rest of your
system is much more correct right um and
so there was this line of work to build
operating systems and type safe
languages so what does it mean for a
language to be type safe and memory
safe the compiler that's a very very
good
question
so B uh if the compiler accepts it then
you're guaranteed that you won't have
any memory corruption
and right right so if your program type
checks then you have no dangling
pointers no uh accidental null pointers
and if some if it says something is of a
type then it is of the type right and so
in languages like C you don't have this
because if you have a pointer or
something it could really be a pointer
to something else and this is how a lot
of bugs happened right um and so the
direction that this work was trying to
take before verb was people were trying
to build operating systems in type sa
memory St languages like C the idea is
if you can build your language in that
you already have that base level of
guarantees and you can just prove
additional functional correctness on top
of that right and so most operating
systems they're built in very low Lev
languages like C and assembly and um
it's really hard because you have to
start with verifying memory properties
of that if you want to verify functional
properties in addition right and so the
approach we took was was well um oh wait
before I get to that I need to say so
with the c operating systems there was u
a problem because there are parts of
operating systems that need to be low
level do people know yeah what parts
page table Yeah the page tables
interrupts interrupts yeah like anything
having to do with like hardware and
memory right like you can't really write
your operating system in C because
there's just all these calls that are
unsafe to the level code right that um
subvert all your guarantees because when
you live in C your the guarantee is well
if everything is written in C then we
have all these nice guarantees but once
we're outside of that once we call out
we could subvert all of our guarantees
and mess up all of our memory right um
and so the approach we took with verb
was we verified a very lowlevel small
sub part of the kernel that we call the
nucleus which is like the page tables
the interrupts the hardware uh interface
and uh the memory stuff to set up the
stacks and do context switching and all
that and then we exported an interface
to the C code with this uh guarantee
that the lowle code doesn't mess up the
heat so it doesn't mess up like anything
the garbage collector is doing in the
allocator um and the high level code
doesn't touch the stack stuff and there
are also some verified garbage colors in
there that um that the GU had buil
before can you say a little bit more
about how you verified the nucleus yeah
yeah so I'm going to talk more about
that yeah um but the cool thing about
Verve was we did it using Boogie which I
just showed you on the previous slide
and so um so horic Works um so so
essentially we verify the nucleus to
satisfy a specification that it uh could
preserve end to end type safety and
memory safety and um so a slight
motivation for it is you know things
crashing so I already told you guys
about this but uh when I gave a talk on
verb I had this int sequence that was
the PowerPoint crashing and then
everything crashed um and I spent like
my time practicing the timing of that so
people thought it was a
surpris yeah so um so in uh inverve the
axioms are the actual assembly inst
instructions so do people remember from
the paper what the axioms were all of
them all the a in the paper well so so
like uh hor had ATI a bunch of stuff
about math right so back then all
programs were just adding numbers to
each other something that so he had
talked about you know addition is
communative associative and like you
have distributive properties and all
this other stuff right and so those were
the building blocks uh off of which you
could do the rest of everything else and
so in our system the building blocks
were the assembly instructions and so um
we wrote the rest of the system in terms
of assembly instructions that we had
acclimatized the specifications of and
so in Boogie um procedures without
bodies are just ax axum so um so you are
asking you know what happens if you
can't prove something well in Boogie you
just don't put a body and
it it lets you just pretend it's an
axium um so for us what we did was um
for things like load so load is an
assembly instruction that reads a
pointer value from memory and so the
return of load is so load takes a
pointer and the requirement is that the
pointer is a valid memory address and so
meem outer is a function that we Define
somewhere else um also it has to be
aligned so like we're reading from like
somewhere where a value actually starts
in memory um this load instruction
modifies the instruction pointer EIP and
so in the next slide it might become
more clear how you were actually
modeling registers if you care about
that and then um what load ensures is
that the uh value that it is returned is
a valid word so it's like a memory align
word and that the value is equivalent to
what we're modeling in memory at the
pointer location pointer
and so um so we have a set of assembly
instructions that we are treating as
axioms like load store ad and bunch of
other stuff desate uh was was coming up
with the guarantees about the assembly
instructions like a significant portion
of the work um yeah so um so I didn't do
that part of the work but Chris did but
he spent a lot of time writing a giant
specification of what it meant for the
high L code not to touch the stacks and
the low level code not to touch the
heaps yeah what I did was just write
everything else to like conform to that
yeah yeah but yeah that that was really
tricky and um so that is what's that is
trusted right now but um so after so I
had interned with Chris and Chris had
another intern who was supposed to
verify certain properties on top of that
but they never finished that but yeah
but that that specification is really
hairy cool
yeah I think they did finish that
actually a publication earlier this year
that was a continuation of verb and oh
right yeah no he did finish that yeah
sorry just point ofation yeah yeah with
um there are a couple I think there are
like three interns okay yeah there were
a lot of people okay cool yeah so so
that might have
finished yeah terminated there's a post
um yeah um so how how this worked was um
so we wrote Boogie that looked like this
that called our uh atise assembly
instructions so this is something that
reads from the keyboard and checks the
keyboard status you don't really have to
know what happens here I'm just showing
it to give you an idea of how the whole
thing was constructed and then we had a
trusted translation of that to actual
assembly and so we wrote uh Boogie our
Boogie assembly um and we also um we
modeled our registers by declaring
Global variables that corresponded to
our registers that got translated to
reg care about that um and so yeah this
this translation was trusted but this
whole thing was verified
automatically so the paper talks about
goto being probably terrible which I
believe when I read it um but you're
using goto was
that like how be handled that and well
also end actually being easy the end
well the thing with go being terrible if
you if you can avoid it you should but
like when you're writing really low
level stuff you have to do it sometimes
well like how does it end up being not
that difficult to do in
um well
so well so it's it's very easy to write
in Boogie so is the question like does
Boogie have trouble verifying things
about it so well for go-to like if you
just if you abstract it correctly like
this is a function the was actually just
like this calling that function so it
really depends on how you encod it okay
yeah um
yeah um cool so uh a summary of what was
verified um so the green stuff is what
was verified so there was a verified
allocator and garbage collector uh the
code to set up Stacks can do stack
contact switching is verified and then
the the interrupt tables and also the
interface to the hardware devices is
verified and then all the hardware ised
classification of the hardware and the
memory bounds that is
trusted sorry I'm an ex device driver
rider that's so funny it's so
naive well you know you can't do
everything maybe it's a small subset at
least yeah I'm putting it in red come
on do you expect um and then the
interface specification which you asking
about B um that is also trusted until I
guess apparently they they did something
with it that makes it less trusted
now exactly do you mean by a verified
garbage con what does that imply um so
the garbage collector was uh implemented
in a similar manner to how I described
and so they had properties about what it
meant for the garbage collector to
maintain the wellformedness of memory
and then they used Boogie to verify that
the garbage collector was implemented to
adhere to
that I'm actually interested in what you
mean by
trust oh so trusted means it's not
verified so it's like azed all
right yeah so what verified Boogie that
is also a very good question uh nothing
verified Boogie so Boogie is
trusted but there are approvers that
will give you a proof that you can check
against um something else Boogie doesn't
do that so it's
trusted um so that is
so the so sorry so effectively the very
minimal specification
you moment ago inie was not
simple
imagine all those veric have a lot of
lines of
this
prec
and what veries your PR and corre well
so so the only thing that's trusted is
the specification of the assembly
instructions those are the axioms but
everything else is um so those
preconditions and post conditions don't
have to be correct but they have to
eventually uh verify against the axioms
and also the specification the interface
specification and so if you have the
wrong ones that the verification won't
go
through and so so I guess like the
takeaway point is that what is trusted
is what's down here and what's up there
but everything in between is um is
verified according to Boogie going
through and applying various deduction
rules yeah but I mean like how do you
know that you didn't have
some
your right so the failures in the logic
will be introduced down here and up
there um and so yeah you if you
specified so what I showed you about the
keyboard that if you had a failure in
your logic there then the system
wouldn't verify um so I guess there's
nothing you introduced that validates
this verifications like it does the
thing that you wrote it to do but it
doesn't right right exactly so the
verification only verifies that um your
your axioms and your your axium satisfy
your specification but nothing else yeah
other
questions when you have a bug in your
axioms does that like Cascade through
does if you ATI false then you can prove
anything in terms of like actual
implementation costs like when you came
up with bugs in your specification like
was it really cost it to fix or was it
like oh we messed this up and then like
the solver fixes helps you fix the so
sometimes what happens is like you
actually can't verify what you thought
you could verify and then it turns to be
a specification error so that's like a
very common thing that
happens um yeah so to give some idea of
the context there has been a lot of
other work that has verified more
functional properties of operating
systems so around the time we did this
work there's this
project4 they um are a verified version
of The L4 micr krel so4 is implemented
in C and assembly they have like a very
small amount of trusted assembly that
they trust and then their C code they
verify functional properties of that and
how they do that is very hard um so they
they have a c implementation they have a
Hol reference implementation that does
the same thing as their C implementation
they prove equivalence of those two and
then they prove properties on top of the
Hol implementation and that's pretty
much what you have to do to get
functional properties out of C
programs um there's also like really if
you're interested in this stuff there's
like really really really cool recent
work on like verifying hypervisors and
there's this paper at um Yale that
recently came out where um so so cool
like tangent they also use horr logic
it's relevant guys um is that um before
to build up your entire verified system
you kind of had to verify the bottom and
then verify the next thing on top of
specific things to the bottom layer and
then every layer um couldn't really
export like a fully abstract interface
to the next layer and so all
verifications had to go all the way down
but there are these guys at Yale who um
figured out a way to define a logic that
let you abstra over implementation
details of each layer and so you could
just like export a specification for
your hypervisor that was like
independent of certain functional things
of the implementation which is very cool
and they also use horr logic so um yeah
like the Y project or the yant group if
you're interested look into
that um yeah so now uh to wrap up uh I
since most people probably don't verify
um software uh all the time I uh thought
about some ideas we can you know apply
to our everyday lives and I asked some
of my friends who also work on this
stuff what they think so this is a
communal set of ideas to take home um so
the first thing is that you should uh
always think about correctness right
like even if you're programming in
Python and you have no types and you
have no static guarantees you can still
write a specification for your program
and you know like documentation
generators like Sphinx do a really good
job of asking you like what are you
returning what are your input types and
this program do right and so even if
there's nothing checking your
specification it really helps yourself
and also anyone using your code lader if
you write down a specification and think
about what what invariance what
guarantees your program should preserve
right um also uh it really helps to
choose a language that helps you us them
right so so um so what I mean by this is
um if your language gives you type
safety and memory safety guarantees you
are not worrying about if you have ding
ling pointers for instance um and also
if your language has types you're not
worrying about something so like a bug I
always have in Python is I forget my
return statement like a bunch of stuff
breaks and like you know a bunch of
minutes later it's like oh I forgot the
return right if you have a language that
checks your types that doesn't happen um
and so it just reduces a lot of
cognitive load and so if you can you
know using a language like that will
start you off at a higher place of
reasoning So when you say typed you mean
statically Ty yeah statically typed are
Dynamic yeah so strongly statically
typed languages really give you a boost
well what if you're using a dynamic
language with static type chter that
would also help so like any anything
that that can check your program before
you run it really
helps um also you reading papers really
help so I've been talking to some people
who they're not academics but they you
know read ideas from academic papers and
they build systems and so like how many
of you have heard of the meteor
system right so it's this like reactive
JavaScript web framework that was based
on the Luna system that was built at AA
which is actually based on this
functional reactive programming paper um
based on this system called Flapjacks
that came out of Academia like a bunch
of years ago and so a funny story about
that paper or a fun story is that um the
professor so um it was like an
undergrads paper and the professor was
like this is not me s i really even want
to publish this and it ended up having
all this impact um and it had impact
because first of all the kid published
it but secondly um someone picked it up
and said this is really interesting I
want to build it for my company and then
I want to quit my company to build for
real right and so so you know like some
things have to happen but reading papers
is a good start um also um you know play
with research tools I think um a lot of
people learn High School not because
they want to build systems in high
school but because it trains you to
program in a way that um makes you a
better program in other languages if you
end up making your own language you
learn certain Concepts you get a feel
for what certain language features can
do for you and so uh relevant to hor
logic are these tools so um Z3 is an
automated prover it's pretty much what a
lot of automated tools compile down to
so they will compile down to Z3
constraints um and so so yeah I guess
what I should say is Z3 is a constraint
solver you can give it constraints about
numbers about uh lists functions I think
it
yeah objects and a bunch of other stuff
and uh it will solve constraints for you
um and so Boogie compiles to Z3
constraints and uses Z3 as its
constraint solving back in and so it
ises dapne which is a uh horr logic pro
for objectoriented programs um and
Boogie and maybe even dapne have like
online interfaces to play with them so I
really suggest doing that there's also
um if you want to put a lot more work in
things like Haw and Isabelle these are
interactive theorem provs which means
that instead of you writing
preconditions and post conditions and
having it verify you write something you
want to prove and then you guide the
approver through a bunch of steps like
okay you break this into these cases and
then um you know this is what you do in
this case you apply this deduction rule
in this case Etc some people really like
it they say it's like playing
Starcraft so you know you might like
it um yeah so also um be patient with
research um if you're using a research
tool it probably won't work a lot of the
time um but the point of it is not to
work all the time it's to work sometimes
and eventually lead to things that do
work so
yeah and uh yeah now we uh get to the
Pop Quiz part of the talk so that um you
can tell me what was talked about so
what main issues did this paper address
R gol yeah that was a really big issue
correctness correctness
yeah sorry
cor yeah provable correctness right so
how do we express things to be provably
correct and then how do we prove them
right um why do we want to prove
programs correct save lives save lives
yeah otherwise we could die
right uh so yeah what were hor specific
contributions to software verification
triple
yeah the triple um and also what should
we be doing when we leave
drink after that take the stairs GRS and
programming yeah after taking the stairs
and drinking
programing what okay so problem is
translating from
your proof to a real program there's a
programming language called ATS that has
a buil-in proof assist okay go beyond
the like what a normal type system will
give you you can kind of Define your own
types of proof that you would like to
Pro about program
nice nice yeah there's also um if you
guys want to know the new cool thing to
learn that's not H school it's actually
idas um it's a dependently typed
language that um is more obscure than
High
School you have types that depend on
terms it's really wild
I haven't
even Idis i r i s it has um types that
depend on terms dependent types so you
can like have like very strong
guarantees about your program yeah I
haven't even learn it yet so that's how
cool that
is just move all your programs into the
type system actually wram
yeah yeah so um so cool now that we all
know what we to do after we can finish
um here's a very cool retro picture of
Tony back then and now so you can see
how people
Eng so yeah in this talk we have find a
way to characterize programs and
properties so horror was instrum
instrumental in defining that and since
then people have built tools to
automatically and also interactively
check programs and their properties and
then um you know some people can
so yes so um I just want to make a
comment about program um I'm
huge
actually um so people often talk
about inol for example there's no way of
really modeling program attention so I
could write a program function called
that takes two integ performs a
subtraction term and has tell me if that
program is correct anybody looking at
that program would say it's not correct
that's why have Quick Check yeah so
there's kind of like what I like about
interest actually is that interest is
actually moving Direction start specify
constraints so they can actually start
to specify program attention right right
but I just I don't like the word um
people use the word correctness in a way
that's not that's a little too broad um
I I think people qualify more because
correctness if your program doesn't do
what you intended to do it really
doesn't matter Ty chck right yeah well I
mean it's a
right if you're like I don't know doing
things with strings instead of doing
things with integers that's even further
away
yeah yeah so every time I read about uh
grou solvers or uh see presentations
like this the example is always basic
arithmetic I can prove that you can sum
up the things in an array yeah but I
actually want to do more complicated
things in my
programs how I can I have trouble seeing
how you make that leap from asserting
that X plus one is greater than x to
showing that the result of a random
number generator is a uniform
distribution of random numbers so if you
want to do that you also need
probability in your pro um so I mean
there are provs that do that so there's
this thing called um probabilistic
relational upstar but um but I mean a
lot of these solvers they only have they
don't have theories like those deep
theories of numbers built in and they
just have linear uh integer arithmetic
and then um uh so so essentially like
all the things that you want to do are
have to be built up of that and so a lot
of so I guess there are like different
classes of properties of what you can
prove about programs and so a lot of
basic correctness properties are just
based on linear arithmetic like memory
wellformedness is just like you like do
some memory operations and those are
just numbers there's no like probability
distribution in that right but if you're
doing random number generation with
probabilistic stuff and all that like
you do need like a a theory of like
probabilistic numbers for that that's
like another layer does that make
sense yeah I think well it sounds like
you're saying it's hard to prove higher
level properties well I guess what I'm
saying is like the basic level like what
most what most verified software is
verified off of right now is not that is
just like the linear arithmetic that
that is built up off of the small
examples that are presented and then
like if you want to do that like there's
like a whole other like there's whole
other theories of like how you prove
that and that's like the next level so I
guess it comes back to what what this
gentleman was saying is that it it will
prove you may be able to prove that my
algorithm is impl
corre well I mean
there if your program isn't doing what
you tell it to do I guarantee it's doing
what you want it to do so there sort
of if your program is not doing what you
what you tell it to do I can guarantee
it's not doing what you want it to do
what you need it to do itely yeah so
there there sort of there's multiple
levels of corre absolutely that but
that's still orthogonal to what we're
discussing what we're discussing is
whether or not programs could be
actually correct so it's a question of
abstraction really and matter being able
to mod well what I'm trying to say is
that if you have a higher level problem
and you want to verify that it is
correct what you need to do is prove
that all of the various things that
you're building that higher level
problem with are correct themselves so
write Lumas you like a will do uh
you write you know an interactive uh
proof of all the various building blocks
that you're doing you verify those and
then you could then imply through
deductive reasoning that that your
higher level program is
correct it's difficult to explain in a
presentation but so there also like
different dimensions of correctness
right so for every so you have different
theories and so like what I mean by
theory is there are a set of rules defin
in a world um so there there's
like thing is
happening yeah so so essentially like
you have these different uh closed
worlds in which you can verify different
things right and so in the world where
you just have integers and you have are
like integers and floating Point numbers
or you know some model of them and then
like linear operations over those you
can verify a certain set of things and
so the property that you are describing
you can't verify in that world you have
you need like this other world that has
like this notion of probability to model
that and so that like so that's the so
if you go to a presentation that's like
the the next next next level
presentation where are talking about
like theories of for verifying that they
will talk about that but it's not it's
in a different different space of
definition in the basic stuff yeah so a
lot of the things that we've been
talking about are trying to prove
positive
qualities but one interesting
application of this is using constraint
solvers like STP to find exploits for
binaries yeah there's an interesting
paper that came out a few years ago from
car automatic exploit generation if
you're curious about I suest Che
out yeah
um terms of the you know the
state-ofthe-art for for
provs uh have any of them been applied
to proving correctness of concurrent
systems yeah so um there's some work on
that I don't know the work very well but
um I think there's a there's at least
one project that I know it's called
called chalis at Microsoft research
where um they were trying to develop a
logic for proving the correctness of
concurrent systems but um concurrent
systems are one place where you really
uh proving it correct is a really good
idea because you can't express all the
possible inner leavings and it's really
really hard to test if not impossible
and so there has been a bunch of work in
that space yeah I just I can't Point
other specific things I also take a look
at Peter alar thing called Molly that
the paper's coming out soon that's like
system specs in the program to test
distri system currency stuff it's really
great but I mean this kind of
illustrates like the point is that it's
not necessarily hard to prove some of
these high order things like concurrency
or probability or necessarily proving
probably runs along very similar rails
to what simple arithmetic proving does
the hard thing is actually just modeling
the the stuff that you're working with
like integer arithmetic is easy because
you have like you know like you know use
something representation or something
where you have all these easy like IND
things you can just get from it when
you're talking about like you know
something like Curren or whatever like
what are your atoms that's that's where
yeah well also modeling it in a way that
you can actually verify properties
automatically so good book if you're
interested like actually playing
software foundations
but then you get to basically just like
run through a bunch of code and fill in
the proofs
yourself and
comp
right thank
you